[Music]
in daydream news Deathwing daydreaming
submitted by eat your vegetables I love
vegetables
yep I love meat research suggests that
Americans spend up to four years of
their life escaping reality that's it I
do way more than that - way more years
of your life yes I think it's way more
technically every time you're on social
media that's escaping your life every
time you plan a video game that's
escaping our life every time we're
watching a movie at the scaping our life
yep
TV show for years seems like so little
plug should be like 10 or 20 years I'm
pretty sure Geno racked up about like
twelve babaca hundred percent sure I'm
pretty sure it's like more than her age
right now she has a side a little yet
because I remember when I lived many
many imaginary lives and most of my time
was spent on the bed
yeah so there were just study with two
thousand adults across the u.s. amount
of emissions by a tour operator gee
adventures and so what they showed is
that after surveying everybody they
found that accumulation Americans spent
about four years
escaping throughout their entire life
and so the breakdown is so the average
person spends 22 minutes each day
daydreaming in this happen yeah like
what's the average training I'm dating
me like five hours a day
ah I'm like successful as [ __ ] and I
daydream a lot every time I'm driving
I'm daydreaming that is a terrible thing
to do so I'm driving and I Drive more
than 22 minutes a day or do you do with
your driving though fron you you does
everything else but driving what is me
what are the comments Damon when I'm
showering I'm bay dreams this was
clearly I'm really good at gauging how
much I'm is like breathing you don't
focus so [ __ ] right
not wrong so they're saying that the top
five moments that were most likely to be
dream is while watching TV listening to
music at your desk or place of work
browsing on social media and driving top
five and then the top ten daydreams is
winning the lottery going call you and
travelling to some more exotic sex being
on a beach doing something adventurous
speaking my mind meeting the one
quitting my job errands and I need to do
the lottery thing is something I always
did dream about yeah number one a
daydream about all of that except
quitting my job and doing errands I
don't know anybody that daydreams about
errands so all I do you so you doc do
you think about oh my god do the laundry
right now oh hell yeah no no no you just
you're just running through what you
have to do in your mother yeah actually
have dreams about doing errands what's
called a nightmare okay all right what I
know I'd not buy tickets to your dream
period I think no no okay see it gets a
little crazy but in the moments where I
feel like I'm really stressed and I feel
like I have a long my mind I start
dreaming about the things I have Oh
like literally dressed going on and it's
on night I already took the test oh I
strive to be sick Aaron oh oh my god do
I get anxiety like last night last night
right I had to change my car
registration because of my new address
right yeah I started getting [ __ ]
anxiety I looked at I looked at my watch
it's only been five minutes and I swear
I was navigating through the [ __ ] DMV
website for like 20
oh and I can't do this I can't I can't
do this [ __ ] no you can a dandy website
saw this is fire I finish it and you
know what else is stupid
so BlueShield right they [ __ ] cut off
my health insurance you know it's not
their fault I change the credit card
information on your website but [ __ ] you
BlueShield
cuz you like that offending snail mail
what the [ __ ] dude I don't know any like
company big company today that doesn't
have online services except for these
[ __ ] shitty ass government things like
geo bein with Porsche you had to send
like [ __ ] what was it like a paper
check to pay every month remember oh
yeah I don't know why I liked the more
submit it that I walk away from the
dealership I don't know why they can't
just set up automatic automatic
withdrawal yeah I had to write a check
and then I had to apply for automatic
withdrawal you have to do that on your
own yeah that's why it's like why you
but but the part that sucked was their
website wouldn't accept it for like the
longest time do you should be able to do
everything online nowadays I think
anything no entitled and it's like what
the [ __ ] dude they didn't they didn't
tell me they said it they said he snail
mail a semi snail mail that I had to
redo my new cut like what I who reads
the mail I don't want to destroy paper
and trees [ __ ] it should be everything
should be online at this point
especially the DMV and everything can be
done online maybe not to the DMV almost
[ __ ] renewal it can be done online
you should be able to sit at your
[ __ ] desk take a picture of your
[ __ ] face at your desk and then put
it on that you should be you're right
yeah you should be it's really easy I
mean it's really archaic the way that
they do it now it's [ __ ] dumb man why
don't we start at all that the [ __ ]
coupons in the mail they just get our
emails and just email it I hate doing
like I have like an entire trash bin
full of that [ __ ] or they should just
[ __ ] mark it off at the supermarket
anyways going back to this escapism
thing they're saying that one should be
6:00 p.m. in the day okay doctor sneeze
Bob [ __ ] the sneeze up Sam don't you do
as we're saying that at 1:56 p.m. is the
time of the day on Monday is the time of
the day that you're most likely to
daydream 156 exactly how did I get that
down to a scallion well that is just
2,000 people that they study so they're
also saying that 7 in 10 struggle to get
out of their comfort zone and take up
new adventures 25% of these people worry
that they won't
get a chance to really indulge in
real-life adventure quick their job be
homeless what you'll be fine
what's the real life adventure is it
like when you tell yourself I've always
wanted to do this but they never do it
like that maybe like getting in a car
and just driving to nowhere okay that
sounds like playing long oh it kind of
sucks for like I think for everybody
because when you have responsibilities
in a job and you don't have this
constant influx of money which is like
everybody
yeah like dreams are literally stopped
by time meaning that you have to
dedicate X amount of time at work and
then you're a lot of this vacation so
let's say you want to go to 12 countries
right but you're only a lot vacation
once a year that's 12 years of your life
that you get to do that when in reality
if you had the money income you could
not there on one year you know what's
crazy
the fact that she just said seven out of
ten people are afraid to take those
risks and get out of their comfort zone
that's what is also holding a lot of
people back but maybe I'm thinking about
my case and I would love to go to the
countries I want to do and knock it out
in the year and then move on from that
and I'm one of those seven people
because I daydream about camping with
the homeless people but I get scared
oh dude can I just cannot because we're
talking about homeless people can I just
bring this up yesterday we can no you
may not
we were doing this photo shoot and it
only anyway and it only brought up to
this point where people do not
understand once again the type of [ __ ]
that you go through with certain
homeless people in LA got cursed out
three times yesterday I'm span of like
an hour you're in their area of course
no we were just shooting and this lady
comes up right so there's like a parking
meter I know what you mean I mean I live
in downtown yeah they just cut at me for
another like they think they're helping
you by parking like come closer
got you guys so they could ask for money
after right so the lady comes out I'm
like my car parks by itself I don't need
your help it's not the life that well
it's already part she comes out she goes
I got you don't worry yeah my I thank
you she goes no you got some money for
me and I'm like I'm sorry I mean I don't
have any cash she goes don't say sorry
don't say sorry I'm sorry I'm like oh
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm not sorry but as a courtesy I'm
saying that but now I want to kick you
in your [ __ ] chest you [ __ ] and then
says holy as after she's I said that
she's like done yelling and cursing
cursing me out right I do comes up line
he goes hey man I notice about for you
guys are here you guys got 45 cents to
spare first of all is a very specific
number I don't what the [ __ ] that means
right and I'm like sorry man I don't got
any cash you know [ __ ] you I'm like two
times in a matter of two minutes then we
walk across the street right after we
get our photos done this lady is a
crackhead she's like this in the back by
the way
she's like this like doing this [ __ ]
right and it a do box up he goes what's
up ho clearly they have a [ __ ]
working relationship I'm holding Yoshio
and that guy to that walked up to her by
the way they called her a ho we were
shooting something she just walks up to
us right he goes cut ha ha ha ha ok I
had a go for brochure doesn't go go for
broke oh that's tell me how you really
feel
and then our homie Remy he's just
telling that right he goes hey you're
doing a good job I said
Remy's just like mother you know what it
means and legs poking at him and then
we're going across the street then he
goes god Chad [ __ ] over it then after
that I'm holding Yoshi shoes cause he's
shooting the photo front he walks up to
what after he's having the conversation
with his cracked-out girl that's cool
like this is [ __ ] still excuse me sorry
to bother you but lady back there
she got me shoes so I wonder if you
could give me Oh spare sounds like these
aren't spare shoes either his well is it
a matter of [ __ ] an hour and I'm like
dude this is the time people don't
understand why is sometimes it's hard
why sometimes I think homeless people
getting nautical it because you get
cursed out you get all this like crazy
[ __ ] that happens I get asked for [ __ ]
every day
yeah keypoint rides and using your
pocket and just here I got a penny
though know what's going to happen is
that somebody's going to come out saying
they're gonna be like you know can I get
45 cents I only got 44 I'll take that
but you ask is 45
can't do it bring yes because I contend
to that point now because I getting
cursed out too often it's too much you
just have a cursive Bowl face but he's
not just me with the other people too
I know I could see why they want to
curse you out though every time I see
you I wanted why cuz I even do the whole
thing right do the cartoon thing right
do this I got nobody your eyes really
don't have [ __ ] you know I'm showing I
don't have any cash and even if I if I
did I would get them like a buck or
something but I don't have any don't
they stop it you ain't sorry don't say
sorry you want to talk about people that
daydream all day oh boy some people in
LA they're not necessarily always
homeless people but there's so many
people that talk to themselves that I
feel normal
there's just people that always talk to
themselves they just having a full-on
conversation about all kinds of [ __ ] and
it usually requires like being angry at
someone there's all people are having
imaginary arguments but then it started
making me think like are there just a
lot of spirits in LA that I don't see
but these people see and maybe I'm the
one that's not right here
hello everybody if you liked the video
make sure that you guys leave us a
thumbs up because if not I'm gonna find
you where you live and I'm going to hug
the [ __ ] out of you with you other than
that you know there's like more videos
up there bro
you
[Music]